Above the line is a simple and powerful thinking model that helps you get the most out of your
unique potential by providing you a clear overview on how you choose to respond to the
emotional pain you can experience as you move through the different challenges.
We all face challenges, losses, failures and setbacks.
The difference with champions is in how they respond.
When we choose to move above the line, we roll, which is short for responsibility.
We take responsibility for our results.
This helps us explore options.
As we explore options, we open up to see and find the learnings in the experience.
When we do this consistently over time, we develop a healthy response to pressure.
Our mindset power increases dramatically.
But it's not always so simple to do.
In fact, human behavioural researchers have proven that human beings are motivated to move
away from pain twice as much as they are motivated to move towards pleasure.
And this can cause you to choose to drop below the line and jab, which is short for justify.
We justify our results and our actions.
We make excuses and we blame circumstances and other people, all in an attempt to avoid
emotional pain.
Ultimately, the choice is ours to make, jab or roll.
And all progress starts with awareness.
We have seen many champions choose to roll under extremely challenging circumstances.
Every time we choose to roll, we are building the mindset muscle of champions.
Consistency over time, prevails.
The major benefit in using this thinking model is it reminds you of where you are playing
in your response to pressure.
Helping you recognise how long you are staying either above or below the line, allowing you
to shift your response when needed.
Remember, even the mentally strongest champions drop below the line at times.
But the difference is they don't stay there very long.
Instead they choose to keep getting back up, above the line and over time this is what
helps make them mentally strong.
Changing the meaning you place on your performance experiences can allow you to choose to move
above the line more consistently.
It was Michael Jordan who said, I have missed more than 9000 shots in my career.
I have lost more than 300 games, 26 times I have been trusted to take the winning shot
and I missed.
I have failed over and over again in my life and that is why I succeeded.
Here we see Jordan sharing with us an insight into how he chooses to respond to the same
pressure we all experience.
Congratulations, you have completed your overview on above the line thinking.